choose all the relationships that are
described by the following equation
y is equal to 7 8 x all right let's look
at these relationships relationship a
a bouquet of eight daisies cost seven
dollars at flora's flowers a bouquet of
12 daisies costs 11
the equation describes the relationship
between the number of daisies x and
their price at floors flowers y so let's
look at scenario a so our x is the
number of daisies
and our y
our y is their price our y is the price
so when we get eight daisies when we get
eight daisies they say it costs us seven
dollars
when we get 12 daisies they tell us that
it costs 11 dollars so let's see whether
this relationship right over here is the
same as this relationship right over
here so if i were to take so let me
write this right over here
so here it says y needs to be equal to 7
8 x so let's figure out what 7 8 x is
equal to
so 7 8 x so if i take 7 8 times 8 well
that's going to be 7. let me write this
down 7 over 8 times 8 is equal to 7. so
this checks 7 8 x is the same as the
price that they gave us so so far these
two seem consistent at least based on
this first data point now let's look at
7 8 of 12. 7 8
times 12. let's see if we divide 12 and
8 each by 4 this is going to be the same
thing as 7 times 3 over 2
which is the same thing as 21
over 2 which is equal to 10.5
so if y were equal to 7 8 x 12 daisies
would cost 10.50 but we just learned
that 10 12 daisies cost 11
so these two things
these two things aren't equal to each
other aren't equal to each other so we
this is not the same relationship in
this scenario y does not equal 7 8 x so
we can rule
this one out
let's look at relationship b
there's a 12.5 percent discount for
every item at crazy joe's the equation
describes the relationship between a
given item's price before the discount
and after the discount
so here they're giving us a percentage
they're giving us a percentage and this
equation right over here it's written as
a fraction so let me at least convert
this into a fraction and see what kind
of a fractional discount this is and
maybe i can construct an equation and
see if that equation is the same as this
one here so 12.5 percent so 12.5 is the
same as literally the same thing so 12.5
is the same thing as 12.5
over
100 and if we multiply the numerator and
denominator by 10 that's the same thing
as 125
over
1
000.
let's see if we can simplify this a
little bit if we divide the numerator if
we divide the numerator
by let's see if we divide the numerator
well actually it looks like they're both
divisible by 125. we divide the
numerator by 125 we get 1. we divide the
denominator by 125 we get 8. 8 times 125
is 800 plus 200 which is a thousand so
this is the same thing as 1 8. so
there's really there is a 1 8 discount
for every item at crazy joe's
the equation describes a relationship
between a given item's price before the
discount and the price after the
discount so let's just think about that
the price after the discount based on
the information they gave here is going
to be equal to the price before the
discount
minus the discount so minus 1 8 of the
original price
well what's x minus 1 8x or another way
of thinking about it what's 1x minus 1
8x well that's just going to be 7 8
x
so this relationship is the exact same
as this one over here the price after
the discount is 7 8 of the original
price so we can we can feel good about
this one these two are the same
let's look at scenario
c and i will do scenario c in orange
a ticket to the paintball arena costs
seven dollars and comes with eight
paintballs every extra paintball costs
one dollar
the equation describes the relationship
between the number of paintballs x and
their price y so let's look at this
we'll do something similar to what we
did up here so we'll have x
which is the number of paintballs
and then we have y which is their price
and then we will think about what 7 8 x
would have been equal to and let's see
if y is equal to 7 8 x
so when we get eight paint balls so x is
the number of paintballs so when we get
eight paintballs the price is seven and
if we take 7 8 x so 7 8 times 8 is
indeed 7. so in this scenario for this
data point it is true that y is equal to
7 8 x
now let's get a couple of other data
points and we might have to construct
these so every extra paintball costs a
dollar so if we have one extra paintball
so we have nine paintballs we have to
pay one more dollars we have to pay
eight dollars and so what's 7 8 x here
so 7 8 times 9 well we don't even have
to compute it this is going to be
something it's going to be like 63 over
8 64 over 8 would be 8. so this is a
little bit less than a little bit less
than 8. but the
important point is that 8 is not equal
to 63 over 8. y does not equal 7 8 x in
this scenario right over here so this
equation does not describe all of these
data points so we can rule that out
finally they say the equation
corresponds to the graph following graph
so let's see if that chord if y equals 7
8 x corresponds to this graph right over
here
so what we're really saying is that for
any x y is going to be 7 8 of that and
the easiest one is to see when x is
equal to 8. when x is equal to 8 7 8 x
would be 7.
when x is 0 7 8 of 0 will be 0. and it's
a linear relationship this tells us that
this is if we have a line and if it goes
through the origin it is a proportional
relationship that the ratio between the
x and the y axis is always going to be
the same or the y and the x or between
the y and the x values is also always
going to be the same
and we know that that ratio is the
correct one the ratio of y to x
throughout this line is seven over eight
here it literally is the numbers are
seven over eight but we can even take
other points that the ratio of three and
a half to four is still the same thing
as seven over eight so this relationship
relationship d the relationship
described by the graph
does coincide with the relationship
described by this equation so i would go
with b and d